[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président de cette
question s'adresser à madame la Première
ministre mais je crois que c'est
monsieur le ministre en industrie qui va
me répondre monsieur le ministre je veux
avec mon collègue Serge babary ici vous
parlez au nom de tous les chefs
d'entreprise sur tous nos territoires
qui nous cessent et qui sont tétanisés
aujourd'hui par l'explosion des coûts de
l'énergie nous nous trouvons désormais
dans une situation où il est devenu
préférable pour nombre d'entreprises de
cesser de produire voire de fermer leurs
portes plutôt que de continuer à créer
des richesses car la production leur
fait perdre de l'argent certains ferment
leurs usines 2 3 4 mois certains
réduisent leur production de 25 à 30%
place leur salarié en activité partielle
à nouveau c'est notre souveraineté
industrielle économique et même
alimentaire qui est en danger tous les
secteurs sont frappés de même que toutes
les tailles d'entreprises elles font
face à cette impasse folle soit signé
des contrats à des tarifs non
soutenables économiquement soit ne rien
signer avant fin octobre comme leur a
suggéré le président de la République en
septembre dernier et se retrouver sans
contrat sans énergie sans activité au
1er janvier car sur le marché les
contrats à terme sont devenus
inexistants les offres quand elles
existent ne sont valables que quelques
heures et ne sont pas accessibles
économiquement le marché sans repère est
devenu imprévisible et personne personne
ne semble vouloir prendre la bride de ce
cheval devenu fou les chefs d'entreprise
sont seuls l'un de mes critères mais
qu'attendent-ils nous mourrons et nous
mourrons de mort subite alors bien sûr
un premier Bouclier a été mis en place
pour les électrons intensives et les TPE
mais je ne doute pas que vous savez
comme nous que le dimensionnement n'est
pas suffisant les critères d'éligibilité
trop strictes les boulangers quand ils
n'ont pas le bon compteur et s'ils ont
un four trop puissant sont aujourd'hui
en train de fermer aussi Monsieur le
monsieur le ministre je vous mettais
Premier ministre monsieur le ministre
aussi monsieur le ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour